what's up reject nation I'm Greg I'm
John Snow
she's all Queen I don't want it dude
you'd like did most of the script right
do it I memorized his lines on tell me
when they remake the show I'm gonna play
Johnson Oh honest trailers Game of
Thrones all you three all right well I'm
sure they'll be covering a lot of the
last season here this is exciting really
excited we have talked about so much
Game of Thrones covered all the episodes
on YouTube did a whole like hour-long
spoiler review now I guess you just
can't leave it behind I wish I knew how
to quit you wants our friends over at
screen junkies put one of these bad boys
together speaking of screen jockeys I
was on two appearances last week with
them screen junkies news episode talking
about directors I love being a part of
that if you guys can go check that out
who would really appreciate it also
they're switching movie fights from
weekly to monthly and I was on like the
big sort of Royal Rumble of movie fights
it was a really fun fun great episode
shouts out to JT he some of the biggest
last I've ever had of watching a movie
but yeah please go check that out with
love if you guys can show your support
there I think that's the only thing that
allows me to cover they're honest
trailers is recommending to go watch
their stuff that I've been on you know
I'm trying to get out here that's
morning I come in on you're just liking
and then unliking and re liking their
video problems you should do to our
videos and also subscribe and hit the
notifications that come anon okay
it was the highest-rated show of its era
the most talked about pop culture event
of the decade
yeah by the end by the seasons one of
the biggest letdowns of TV history
Oh have brought the broken protector of
the realm
this show is coach George RR Martin's
doorstop knows returns but since they
are deeper through those they're going
off in a bi and boy does it feel that
way we're after that season let's go
pull up some bigger highs allows you to
shorten one scramble the tie or the net
Brooke wig I'm on that moment because
majority owners either got bored burnt
out or better than no one like their
slavery idea
featuring huge revelations they really
pay off it was a true king so a new king
yup the Nights Watch relationships that
took years to develop turning on a guy
yep and characters who straighter forgot
their best friends or forgot they have
magic shape-shifting powers or for God
they're at war with I kinda forgot about
Mehran he forgot forgot the biggest Navy
in Westeros existed admitted this is o
show wasn't a lot of applaud for you to
meet a cheer Danny forgot to King's
Landing here the entire city to the
desert they're our main players will
finally collide to see who will sit on
the Iron Throne will the reign of Queen
Cersei continue or will she just stare
out the window
yeah
[Music]
we'll Daenerys continued or surgical
attacks against the ruling class or will
she 420blaze the world when her nephew
won't give her the Dino boys
judge snow do anything for watches and
this I'm tired of fighting I never
wanted a grunt dumb wanted I never want
I told you I don't want it I don't want
it Oh wah wah
though the winner at the end of it all
is the character with the best story and
he was a better story and the brown and
the rookin brand brand yes good
no but like literally anyone else it's
okay if it was guy you remember it's
just a trailer again I'd get so upset
you say goodbye the complex heroes you
come to bar and say hello to their
one-dimensional look-alikes like Varys
but of the dick joke if I must my quiet
drink all the time I don't think it's
requalification as I'm sure you'd agree
you should consider yourself lucky
at least your goals are results because
you have never Littlefinger lower than
one balcony Winterfell
or the Arya Stark reunion tour lady stop
you came home you still have it we don't
hello i'm area
lady stop don't call me that she said
meet me again here we are
you left me to die while the shows were
lively great villains backslide from the
Joffrey ask Ramsay Bolton to the
mysterious night king who after all my
fan theories really was just some dude
Nikhil arouse dad to a tree to this
soggy pickup artist who stole the
Dragons pot armor for himself have to be
honest making the I what - Burton movie
is historic from I think it does a nice
pair electric Nevermore the Pringles guy
damn week bang creatures we live only by
the mothers puts Groot characters
because Game of Thrones can still
deliver some amazing visual spectacles
yes and if you remember how to crank the
brightness on your TV there we go
from the claustrophobic terror the
Battle of the bastards to the crowd
level chaos of the Battle of King's
Landing - 8 guys waiting for help
on a frozen pond I'm after bonus buddy
oh now you use the fire sword rest
assured that in the later seasons
everything will look also and no one you
really care about is gonna die
yeah
see good as new why not the Starbucks
can so there's new words for the show
that managed to both live and swim to
the finish line
just hold the door on giving it cry for
not ending the way you thought they
can't please everybody or four
characters teleporting around you know
to converge at some point or even all
the you certainly didn't please have the
same as bottles no be grateful for a
show that's given us the last communal
experience in our divided world
crabbing on the final seasons of prima
throw no
together Wow miss u doge oh god no no
watch the spin-offs you crazy story
Jack Sparrow master always looks on the
bright side I think we might miss they
do you should be happy as well
[Applause]
Hey yes my queen my queen I enjoyed it I
hope my Queens come on thank you the
Queen's enemies the new Princess
Harry Strickland says propane and
propane accessories
all right our next comedian you might
have seen you're going to the wall give
it up for darlin giant they know it's
one of the you cowards did my pants
what kind of God would have a Becca that
smooth you where's much as to fees I've
always had through life you're a lucky
man
the in service thought might still been
rolling ah crap service
yeah you're just gonna murder me on this
murder show ocean shippers
[Music]
it's good game of Thrones knockoff hazy
[Music]
good boy who's a good boy we're never
forgave you but with a book less nerdy
than ever but still
hell yeah hell yeah
known her since she was 14 you sickos
trying to impress you are impossible to
impress dad I won't apologize for trying
to rescue they obviously had help we
[Laughter]
made a mistake a horrible mistake and
rested a stranger you don't know miss
things I've done I did unspeakable
things don't [ __ ] touch me hey my kid
hairline I mean Arrington oh no never
gonna see that Ice and Fire
I don't fire the hand will always have
the sickest burns
thank you for watching this video but
did you know we also make other videos
with just one quick talk about those
videos now
did you know else to make the lines up
like those intolerant cuz the second
half of that word is dari legendary
nice Barney wow that was I just gotta
say kudos to not only the riders of the
honest trailer but the editors they had
to shuffle through three season reasons
primarily the almost twenty episodes
still that's like a lot of hours you got
a sore throat for the CBS show kudos to
them John Bailey epic voice guy another
amazing job again that I was like
halfway through this going man I cannot
imagine how daunting of a project this
is yeah I got pain it seems intense
enough to do it for a
two-and-a-half-hour movie but to do it
for upwards of 20 hours of television is
impressive and also I mean for me
because it has been a while for some of
us since we've seen seasons 7 or 6 it
was like oh wow like this actually puts
some of the timeline back together for
me there are some characters they show
them like yeah because we've come a long
way and we laid at a long time man I
more can we say I don't know I mean they
mailed every repetitive motif not only
have we spent hours breaking down that
final season
I mean for weeks it seemed like
everywhere we went all people wanted to
talk about was this show yeah it's like
an event we all lived through and and we
all got Loki traumatized by because we
invested in hearts at least bruised a
little bit by the experience you know
what was the lie they had in here about
a show that managed to like slog its way
ends so lick your wounds for the show
that managed to both limb and sprint to
the finish line
yeah it's completely a hundred percent
that is a perfect because like yeah you
start that season eight out and you're
like wait wait wait wait especially
season eight but but yeah you zoom out
and the whole thing starts to feel like
okay yeah this first half and I said oh
we got a lot to do and then in the
second half you're like oh
god were slowdown rumbles yeah what are
you doing yeah that's true it's like
they just couldn't find the right pace
that could satisfy anyone for that final
season
you know I I've had this conversation
quite a bit I haven't I haven't talked
to anyone about the show about how I
find it funny and this is actually a
video I might want to do a topic on one
day how we look at a show especially
coming off the heels of a final season
of a show based off its final season you
know everyone seemed to be judging game
a--throw not everyone but the really
predominant voice it seemed what was
that we judge it based off of its final
season how disappointed that was for so
many people I know not everyone's
disappointed with it it's like people
would judge it off of that and I find it
interesting the way how we'll separate
movies within a movie franchise on its
own like take the x-men franchise people
will be like x-men 2 is great yeah Logan
is amazing but no one watches the lowest
reviewed movie in the franchise Dark
Phoenix and goes all the x-men franchise
sucks now but we can easily distinguish
between those movies and the franchise
and we do it for plenty of movie
franchises but yet we don't do that for
seasons of television like I think
daredevil season 1 is one of the
absolute best seasons of TV I have ever
seen it tells a complete story in that
first season I like the other two
seasons but nowhere near as much as the
first the same thing with Game of
Thrones I'm like look I'm on the train I
the last half of season 8
I really wasn't a fan of like four or
five and six I just wasn't a fan of
those episodes but the first three I
thought were fine you know we run the
people who were like yeah I see in
hindsight all the issues of the night
King moment but there's no denying for
us that that moment we all freaked out
as an EP out those three episodes were
worth the emotional experience like yeah
when Arya stabbed the night king and I
remember like filming that reaction I
adore that that was one of those moments
that just came out of me that I did it a
lot of times you can see like even one
watching Austria like I'm gonna laugh
right now but I'm not like oh I'm
unexpected by that me laughing at that
yeah but I've flipped out I caught
myself at the moment going like you can
see the way I'm like really good
readjusting myself
this happened well yeah like that so I
don't need any more fanservice this year
after that moment like one moment yeah
and there were things in hi inside of
like well they kind of just can all that
there was all that build-up the lore
everything they covered here in this
honest trailer anyway back to my point
it's sad how this final season maybe
because of how monumental and how much
of you worship it had so many people
sort of view Game of Thrones through a
lot of the lens of the whole show has
been greatly affected by its final
season but I still think that you know I
love season 7 I know that's when a lot
of the problems seem to have presented
itself with fan bases but I still love
that season and I think the first six
seasons are some of the greatest
television I've ever seen so I would
never say this show as a failure because
I'm like - I created a final episode Wow
that was a major test but the the show
is ended of itself
to me there's just no denying those
first six seasons are incredible and
it's like they've had the same - head
riders they've been following the george
RR martin formula i think that when they
Benioff and Weiss when they came on to
write this show I think they were under
the impression that the other books
would have come out by that point Oh
totally Martin has said I think a couple
times that he's pissed at himself for
not finishing right so I was like I'll
be done long before they've gotten there
they were suddenly in this position and
Game of Thrones isn't like Curb Your
Enthusiasm or they just feel like yeah
we're coming back to in five years but
sure we're back with new bits yeah like
we're a show like this it means there's
a two-year hiatus but at least it were
still like you know sizzle in that state
for a long time before the show came out
they were putting this unfortunate
position where you're like guess we have
to wrap up came up sorry we have to
finish this story you know the only
thing I have trouble with the sympathy
side on is that by all accounts I've
been able to find in reading it was
their choice to end it where they did
HBO was like we'll give you 13 seasons
you can do whatever you want like we at
least 110 and then when they came in and
said 7 HBO was like what what what what
yeah and they said like we think we need
70 hours to tell this story in
completion I mean that's fair they left
a lot out of the books within those
first five seasons at the same time they
still added things to the show that are
not in the
book so yeah like they still provided
great things for it when they did have
books to work off of it seemed like they
established a nice balance it's not like
The Walking Dead where I think you can
or at least in my experience talking to
people seeing fans online I feel like
it's a little harder to please fans of
that source material with that show yes
whereas Game of Thrones it seemed like
for yeah the first six seasons I would
probably see six yes
they had a really good blend of okay
here's stuff that's directly inspired by
the book I know six doesn't have the
book stuff but it still feels kind of
like it does and then yeah they have
their own new elements and things like
that and I imagine that those they've
been working off outlines for the last
few season so I imagine that the sixth
one was probably the most fleshed out
how long yeah Howard theorize that would
make a lot of sense so that way they had
plenty of material that go off of there
yeah and then that is an interesting
debate to have about the way we judge
seasons of show like installments
because it sequels to a film franchise
or seasons of shows are all installments
of an ongoing story theoretically
definitely I feel like it's it's gonna
boil down to a case by case because
their shows that seem like you can watch
a season or two and kind of check out of
the serialized story and still be fine
like that's the impression I've always
gotten from Dexter is like you can watch
the first four seasons and you don't
necessarily have to finish it if you
don't want to yeah when I was most
seasons of Dexter and in a way like the
whole we gonna do from the next days
yeah whereas Game of Thrones seems like
it it always is heading in this
direction where it's meant to be a
compendium it's mess to be one long
story
that's a fair point and so I kind of
land in the middle because I'm like yeah
this series of books is a series of
books in each book has an ending but
even those books have to clue into
another vesture because not each season
a game of Thrones necessarily ends the
story yeah yes that's a fair point
so it's it's weird it's like I don't
know what to do now because I agree I'm
like I think there is some amazing stuff
that earned its place in television
history that shouldn't be overlooked
simply because the landing was so wobbly
but at the same time I'm like where does
this sit now like what is the
revisitation motivation from what
yeah well how people rank this show yeah
and they completely discount whatever
how do you different feelings they had
yeah how do you average the highs and
lows yeah it's a fair point it's a fair
point I guess is the only thing we
haven't really talked you know we should
do we should just sit down after this
and have a double feature of this and
the game of Thrones Season eight pitch
meeting just call it a night never ever
discuss this i got a sad thing what they
pointed out in the orchestra there are
things we've already yeah like address
ourselves yeah but in their credits
those motifs I've never actually notice
do it do we do such a great thing to
point out like that is so true they
thought that out all the time the amount
of jokes Tyrion makes about Barry's not
having genitals and all those bright
side cracks nothing like that Jon Snow
hairline I think I won't ever keep
noticing that I like his hairline it's
unique I think it's as I have a hairline
you're pretty cool hairline yeah when
your head Buzz for all the game of
thrones that did my hair like that yeah
I think that's always my favorite part
of especially these honest trailers to
deal with like a lot of source material
is this kind of reminds me of a
different version of like the Wes
Anderson one or the more filler inspired
ones where it's like oh wow you're
really breaking down you had the nitty
gritty details and how many things do
get recycled over three seasons or three
alright guys well thanks for watching
make sure to subscribe to screen junkies
you can subscribe the real rejects click
that notification I'll get notified when
we have a new video up and okay